I've heard it tonight as Democratic
congressman ted Lieu his way you need to
know he represents the state of
California in Congress meanwhile
California represents the state of moral
decay in our country he's a member of
the Democratic caucus where he serves as
an assistant whip
I'll ask him for atom shifts safeword
he's a colonel in the US Air Force
Reserve but he won't trick me with any
sexy volleyball montages congressman ted
Lieu everybody it's got to get a little
small talk out of the way no big deal
but who did you vote for in the last
election I thought it for myself would
it yeah what did you vote for I'm not
gonna answer that question I find that
appropriate you have given our president
a pretty hard time
have you given a fair chance I have I
didn't set out to run for Congress to
resist the president
I served active duty in the Air Force I
believe America is an amazing country so
after last November's elections I
actually wrote a memo that said hey
Donald Trump won the electoral college
when the great things about America is
our peaceful transfer of power we should
give him a chance to govern about two
months later I conclude I was wrong
did you did you release that memo
I made it public okay the memo publ I
did yes well I read underlying
information as well you did your
research I did that's your personal
estate you're on the House Judiciary
Committee have you read the memo I have
not but it doesn't mean I can't talk
about it
great for same reason that chairman unis
wrote the memo without reading
underlying information well it's not
about what you know or what you read
it's about like what you understand and
who you want to convince there's only
three things need to know about this
memo great first of all Democrats have a
better super secret memo than
Republicans second a follow up it's a
sequel nobody likes the sequels you
think anybody like Godfather two so
second they're hyper partisan GOP memo
was written based on the Chairman not
actually reading the underlying
information and third there are two
organizations they have read the
underlying information the Senate Intel
committee and the Department of Justice
and chairman you notes won't give them
the memo because he's scared they're
gonna tell him he's wrong well why are
you so scared of this memo are you in
this memo
I'm not scared this memo I just think
the Democrats have a better one do you
think it's gonna come out it doesn't
really matter cuz it's a stupid memo
again the Democrats that be better
super-secret oh the Democrats have a
better plan a better way to deal with
health right do you have a better deal
you didn't have a better path to the
White House I'll tell you that much
you are also pretty critical of Jared
Kushner absolute and you've been pushing
to take away his security clearance
they're showing that he doesn't have
security clearance so this is what we
know about Jared Krishna that he's the
son-in-law of the president and should
get what the hell he wants what that
apparently is what's happening so to get
a security clearance you have to fill
out what's known as the sf-86 security
clearance form i had to fill those out
to get my security clearance they're
very intrusive and they say if you lie
on it you can be prosecuted you're
Kirchner lied twice on two of his
security clearance forms yet a submit
three to get it right in addition he's
under investigation by Special Counsel
Muller's office no one in that kind of
situation so they have a security
clearance so he's got a lot of eyes out
him so he's probably fine well so that's
a good point he is now in a compromised
situation right so foreign powers know
they can leak things whether it's true
or not and put him into even deeper
trouble that's why his security
clearance needs to be revoked
immediately so what do you want to do
about it said somebody was in a position
of power what can you do about something
like that
help me take back the house and we'll
revoke a security clearance
you are on your own here let me tell you
do you have a plan how are the Democrats
gonna take back the house give me your
plan and maybe I'll help you and by that
I mean fortune but listen to the first
part we have a better deal on the
economy this GOP tax scam was really a
bad deal for the middle-class families
83% of all the benefits are you
eventually going to go to their top 1%
of America many middle-class families
are going to end up getting the short
end of the stick and when you look at
all their activism out there these
amazing women's marches you see huge
amounts of voter behavior shift and we
just flip a rural state sentence see in
Wisconsin all their activism and energy
is on part of the Democrats know the
Doomsday Clock just clicked
one more click closer to midnight yeehaw
I guess a you've been pretty adamant
you've you tried to propose and take
away Donald Trump's ability to be to
launch a first strike attack don't you
think now would be the time to give him
that option not at all no we're getting
this much closer to doomsday give that
guy the keys of the car so this is
something I think most people find
interesting how do you launch a nuclear
weapon in America president wakes up one
morning and says hey I'm angry I want to
go nuke some country Sarki defense has
to execute that order the order goes
down through military chain of command
and missiles launch it is that easy
Congress is not involved the judiciary
is not involved there's no way the
framers the Constitution would have let
a small amount of people destroy the
entire world without additional checks
and balances well I think it's it's good
that it's easy for Donald Trump when you
make it too hard that guy's not gonna be
able to do anything with it
so what try and make it harder so my
legislation with Senator Ed Markey is
bipartisan and says before the president
can launch a nuclear first-strike he
first has to get their approval of
Congress the Congress has to agree on
that absolutely I think we're pretty
safe from nuclear war then if that's the
case that's the point of it
congressman Ted Lou